the pop cast Brothers yes they did a
video talking about Stargate and we have
to have a chat about it welcome to
psycheck your Sci-Fi TV and move your
Channel
[Music]
so I think it's fair to say the video
that pop cast did yesterday and their
Unleashed channel was a little Negative
they actually said that at the moment
they would rather the Amazon just didn't
do Stargate that the people in charge at
Stargate at the moment mainly Jennifer
sulky just isn't the right person for
this and they're going to ruin it
now they actually did talk a lot about
how they've got a new source on the
Stargate story and how they feel that a
new project is right around the corner
it is about to be announced and that the
fans are not gonna like what they're
planning now at the moment they haven't
actually gone as far as saying what
those plans are but if you're a regular
site tracker I think you'll have a rough
idea
so let's actually go through a couple of
the points that they made on the video
um a couple of areas where they actually
did get things right and a couple of
areas where I feel they got things wrong
and then we'll have a chat about what I
think about the probability of Amazon
actually being able to do a good show
really are so first of all they talked
about how this new source has told them
the before Mark Fergus pitched for the
new Stargate franchise a new TV show the
Amazon actually had a plan for the show
that it would appear on MGM plus and
they would have a budget of one million
dollars an episode now I went nuts when
I heard this because I've I've never
heard that rumor before and like I say
you guys know that I've been pretty much
on top of this from day one with
Stargate so I was surprised
I was more surprised because the number
is ludicrous and to be fair to the
podcast guys that they said as much on
their video that this number of one
million dollars episode is just stupid
it can't be done a show could not be
made particularly a Sci-Fi show could
not be made for that money let's
remember the SG-1 when it was first Dead
all those years ago had a budget of just
under a million dollars an episode all
the way back then and that was such a
poor amount of money even then that
actually they had to steal some of the
special effects from the movie and cut
them into their show particularly like
the death guide is swiping in and things
and they had to actually repeatedly do
that through the first season because
they couldn't afford their own special
effects now some aspects of CGI Etc are
actually now cheaper so it is actually
in some ways cheaper to produce TV shows
than it was all those years ago
but making a brand new show building
sets hiring sound stages etc etc for a
budget of a million dollars an episode
where you will probably only be making
10 episodes so 10 million dollars
is just ridiculous to put that in
context the rings of power that Amazon
did cost a billion squillion pounds an
episode probably it was a lot the new
Avatar series are Netflix the um not the
blue avatar the you know that's windy
Avatar guy is going to be around 15
million dollars an episode
um things like Jack Reacher enough to
cost about seven to eight million
dollars an episode and even the expanse
which didn't have a big reeling base of
audience was between three and eight
million dollars an episode it averaged
between three and five to be fair but
some of the episodes that were bigger
went up to eight so a series a Sci-Fi
series even going on MGM plus it only
costs a million dollars an episode is
impossible now when they started getting
pitches we know that Mark Fergus pitched
and actually they mentioned this on
podcast yesterday because this was
information I gave them seven or eight
months ago that when Mark Fergus was
pitching he was asking for a budget in
and around 10 million dollars an episode
now the way it works with budgets on TV
shows is look the studio might come in
with this TV show and say look we want
to do it for this sort of money and then
they negotiate the guys developing the
TV show then the show runner will sort
of say well look for this money we can
do this if you give us a bit more money
we can do this blah blah blah they
negotiate now Mark Fergus the guy that
did the expanse for Amazon was
negotiating to develop and then Show run
the new Stargate franchise he was asking
for 10 million an episode but they were
negotiating now I know for a fact that
the figure Amazon came back with was
five million dollars an episode
initially and they were negotiating to
average out at about seven and a half to
eight million dollars an episode now
that is doable money especially
considering the current climate where
all of the streaming services are
desperately trying to cut their costs
they're desperately trying to decrease
budgets and basically across the board
they're looking at a 25 decrease in
normal budgets now if you think of Star
Trek being on average about 10 million
dollars an episode Stargate we would
hope would have roughly the same sort of
budget seven and a half million
considering the current climate is about
right now on podcast they actually then
said that the pitch from Mark Fergus was
dismissed by Amazon because they were
pitching too high because they were
saying it was going to cost too much
money now that isn't true negotiations
with Mark Fergus again if you're a
regular Sidetrack you already know this
ended around December time actually
literally just before Christmas and it
is true that part of the reason why the
negotiations ended was because of budget
but it was also because Amazon just
couldn't decide what they wanted to do
was it a TV show was it a movie would it
go on MGM plus would it go on Amazon
Prime all of these things that Mark
Fergus was asking all of these very
sensible things that he needs to know
because he needs to develop the show to
match what Amazon actually then want
he was not getting an answer for now we
have since found out that it looks like
we're going to be getting a movie there
is a bit more to that which is going to
be following in another video but it
looks like that Jennifer sulky wants to
do five or six cinematic movies a year
and the budget is already there for that
so she's decided that one of those
movies will be Stargate and she has
ordered Claudia Valentini the new head
of film at MGM and Amazon to start the
development work on that and RoboCop
it's that project that we expect to get
announced at San Diego Comic Con or
sometime just after depending on what
happens with the strikes so podcast new
source didn't quite get that right it
was a little bit more complicated also I
should say that Mark Ferguson didn't
actually lose that pitch as far as I'm
aware they just amicably decided to come
back and speak at a later date now we
don't know whether those conversations
happened or not but Mark Fergus and
penguin and parking his company were
doing another big project for Amazon
they knew the writer strike was probably
coming and Amazon asked them to focus on
that and they would return to the
Stargate conversation a little later
so again the podcast boys didn't quite
get that right it is nice to know though
that this source is saying that yes
Stargate is coming I'm pretty sure at
that point now it's like 99 certain that
that is actually true now on podcast
they mentioned that the project that is
about to be announced is one that's not
going to be very popular with fans now
I'm assuming that's because pop cast are
going to say that this is going to be a
movie and nobody wants a movie I
actually asked you guys on a poll some
time ago and actually 91 of you
basically said you want a TV series only
nine percent of you said a movie would
be cool
so 90 of the Gators and that was nearly
2 000 people answered that poll by the
way but 90 Gators don't want to film
speaking to you guys I know that you
guys think and I agree with you that a
film is a massive risk if it fails it
kills the franchise before it even gets
really started also there's a big gap
between SGU ending and Stargate
restarting a movie that will only be
maybe two hours has an awful lot of
questions to answer and can they do it
in a satisfying way I suspect not so yes
I agree that there is going to be an
announcement very very soon and that
announcement is not going to be very
popular but if you're a regular site
tracker I'm hoping you're aware of that
you're ready for that announcement now
and I actually think a lot of you have
warmed to the idea of a movie because at
least we're getting something and in a
way it does show that Amazon are really
determined to actually push forward with
Stargate franchise and put their money
behind it because at the end of the day
this whole nonsense story to be honest
about a million dollars an episode is
not showing any confidence now we know
from talking to people like Jenny Steven
who used to work at Stargate command Etc
that Amazon really do consider this to
be a temple franchise that meaning a big
project something that really is
important something they're going to
hold other things off now I was telling
you guys that a year ago that Amazon
really did consider this to be important
I was telling you guys that even before
that when Brad Wright was still involved
before the sale went through because
Amazon were the potential customer for
Brad Wright's project it was Amazon that
were going to MGM and saying we would
love you guys to make us a Stargate show
it was one of the main reasons why
Amazon bought MGM in the first place I
do not believe this rumor for a second
they even considered one million dollars
an episode considering how much they
overpay for everything else
and that was one of the podcast Brothers
other big points they do overpay as I
say Rings a power cost a billion
squillion pounds every single episode
Wheel of Time Again was very expensive
Citadel 25 million dollars an episode
and it was a complete failure so yes I
imagine if this show is going to be
going straight to MGM that they would be
asking for a much lower budget a point
mark Fergus made during the negotiations
one million dollars episode no three to
five million dollars an episode as an
opening bid now that I could see
the budget for the Billy the Kid who's
probably MGM Plus's biggest or main show
right now that they actually make is
budgeted between three to five million
dollars an episode and I could see them
trying to pitch Stargate at something
similar but then the negotiations would
happen and they would probably get a
little bit more money
however it doesn't look like that is now
the plan so we can move on from that the
pop gas Brothers though were making the
point that Jennifer sulky is not a
popular figure right now with fans
she was in charge when the whole rings
of power up was all green lit she
was in charge when Wheels of Time was
greenlit and that has also been a bit of
a mess
so we cannot trust Jennifer saki to do
this
or can we
yes okay she was in charge when Citadel
was put forward but Citadel was a TV
project that was pitched by the Russo
Brothers the guys that have just had me
now that little bit of success over at
Marvel doing things like end game
so Jennifer salkin gets approached by
the Russo brothers and they say we've
got this idea for this spy show it's
going to be Bond it's going to be almost
sci-fi we'd love to make it with Amazon
and Jennifer salkey says how much do you
want
and gave them the money now I don't
blame her for doing that because
obviously the Russo Brothers had just
come off major success Amazon Studios
getting them to do a TV show for them
was a bit of a coup so of course they
were going to put and then Amazon put
their money where their mouth was
now the show failed it's actually crap
but that's not Jennifer sulkey's fault
and I completely understand the decision
that led to the show being made but
every Studio ever has projects where
they try and they miss they hit some
stuff like you know the boys which is
pretty good even though I'm a little
embarrassed to admit it I love that show
and they miss with some shows look at
Willow that was just on Disney everyone
was so excited about that everyone
thought that was an absolute no-brainer
do a new Willow TV series that will be
amazing I was incredibly excited about
it and it was crap
these things do happen at Studios
particularly a young Studio like Amazon
one of the reasons why they bought MGM
was to get the experience of MGM as well
as the IP they want to do better and
they have done better in lots of ways
because one of the things they didn't
mention on podcast was actually that
there's been a lot of good shows through
Amazon the Jack Reacher series was great
the Jack Ryan series was really good
good Omens was brilliant I personally
love Bosch the TV series I think that's
great and let's not forget that they did
save the expanse and that is one of the
best sci-fi shows in the last decade so
Amazon yes they get things wrong they
waste money massively
but they also do get some things right
and the important thing here is nothing
has actually been announced we don't
know who's going to be show running or
directing if it's a movie we don't know
who's going to be doing the development
work if they do get penguin in a Parker
to come into the development work for
this then I think it's going to be
bloody brilliant but of course if they
put the wrong people in charge it's
going to be awful
so let's hold off our actual judgment on
this until we know a bit more now I put
a poll on late last night asking you
guys will Amazon destroy the Stargate
franchise now a lot of you
think they probably will I think it was
something like 40 but over 50 of you
said look let's give it a chance let's
wait and see and about 10 of you thought
that yeah yeah it'll be it'll be fine
so
let's be honest about this
we need to wait and see
let's not do what a lot of people on
YouTube and a lot of fans did to the
rings of power they destroyed it before
it had even come out now Links of power
was boring but it was not anything like
as bad as a lot of people will tell you
it was and let's really not start the
negativity campaign before it's even
been officially announced
please give them a chance to actually do
something we love because if you go into
this deciding this is going to be a woke
pile of crap rubbish
before you even watch the show when you
sit down to watch it you will find
reasons to hate it it's psychology it's
basic human emotion you can't help it
so let's not start the campaign just yet
let's have a bit of positivity let's
give Amazon the opportunity to work with
MGM and actually do something we can
like whether it's a movie or a series or
hopefully a movie that turns into a
series
let's just be happy we're getting
Stargate back
then later we'll worry about whether
it's any good or not so it'll be very
interesting to see what the podcast
Brothers have to say
I will let you know as soon as I find
out so guys get into the comments what
do you think about everything the
podcast brother said I will drop a link
to the video by the way so you can go
and check it out for yourself do you
think he has a point that actually
Amazon have knocked out the best track
record and we're scared for our lives
here that Stargate is going to get
ruined or do you actually agree with me
and think that actually Amazon have done
some good stuff it depends who they get
in to lead the ship and if they get the
right person we could get something good
and Amazon have a history of putting
their money where their mouth is so we
might even get a decent budget to go
with it get into the comments to tell me
exactly what you think if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification and follow all of
these links that are in the description
and you can go and see lots of fun
Sidetrack stuff you can also go to
patreon.com where most of our new videos
appear first and for a small
contribution each month don't really
supports the channel you get to see them
without the adverts
as always guys please stay safe look
forward to Stargate and I'll see you
next time
foreign foreign
[Music]